my next guest is one of the co-creators
of mr. show and he played Saul Goodman
in Breaking Bad
now he's currently on tour promoting his
new book a load of hooey he'll be at the
Pabst Theater in Milwaukee next week
he's been kind enough to stop by and
read an excerpt please welcome our good
friend Bob Odenkirk if I were if I were
running for president the first thing I
would do is hold a press conference and
get all my skeletons out of the closet
and onto the table skeleton table pick
it up for couple skeletons before I
announce my candidacy for President of
the United States I want to comment on
some rumors and accusations that I'm
fairly certain will come to the fore as
my campaign gains steam I will warn you
I'm going to be more open than any
candidate has ever been so please assure
the children out of the room the first
and foremost accusation will be that I
have cheated on my beautiful wife Betty
I have cheated on my beautiful wife
Betty I have cheated on her more than
once I have cheated on her more than
twice I have cheated on her more than
three times I could go on like that but
I think you got the gist I have cheated
on Betty and brief one-night affairs and
a few long-term ones I have cheated on
her with men
and women and with groups of men and
women and one person who was kind of an
either or if my beautiful wife Betty
doesn't know about this but we will be
discussing it in private soon after this
press conference ends and then later in
public and possibly in a court of law
now I have not always been a willing
participant in these how shall I
characterize them sex games sometimes I
was drunk one time I had a blindfold on
twice I was paid once I did it on a dare
but in at least thirty instances that I
can recall
I was cooperative and willing so don't
get the idea that I'm quick I'm a quick
lay or easy to blind fall back I put
that blindfold on myself now the media
will no doubt suggest that there's
something weird about me wearing a
blindfold while having sex with two
people I'd only met a few hours before
but I assure you I was on ecstasy and I
would have tried almost anything
now a further word about my beloved wife
Betty I have been married to the same
wonderful understanding occasionally
oblivious woman for 32 years and through
it all through all of the sex with other
people all the awesome nastiness I have
stayed married to her with a quiet pride
in myself and what a good guy I am in
all these years I have married only one
other woman and had but one second
secret family and this was in another
state more than 30 miles away and
believe me the added responsibility as
well as the commute was no picnic now my
enemies will try to twist this right and
accuse me of polygamy but it's not
polygamy because neither wife knew about
the other wife and I think that's what
polygamy means right I'm not sure if I'm
right about that but I'm sure I'll find
out soon after this press conference and
I'll get back to you with the definition
clarified by law so there you have it
I've committed adultery pickpocketing
and general scumbag re on a semi-regular
basis and now you know did I fail to
mention my pickpocketing yeah well I'm a
pickpocket I do it all the time can't
help myself I'm sure with the Secret
Service around I'll be forced to cut
back on that exciting little hobby then
again maybe they'll make it easier might
provide cover for me yeah this is gonna
work out great vote for me and let the
pocket picking begin
[Applause]
you have my hose
[Applause]
a break we'll be right back
you